hello rejects I am Greg I am Tony to
make sure no one gets mad at me for
later after done were filming I need a
stargazer sir channels trees Aeon
Instagram there's a video that was
requested couple times first person
requested Jorge Gomez Jorge Gomez
request is up sir
react to working with jigsaw work
working with jigsaw yeah I know there's
a former video to this that's I think
it's called living with jigsaw I didn't
thank you so from the Saw movies yeah I
mean it could be a jigsaw puzzle that
they're living with that sounds very
hilarious I didn't see living with
jigsaw and I've definitely never seen
working with jigsaw this video came out
a few months ago but hey it's part of
the requests right you want gotta give
Jorge Gomez George Greg Jorge Gomez geez
all the Rapids there you go
alright guys no more beating around the
tissue yes the two she needs the
beatings
yes
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
work together to free ourselves I spent
the weekend at home with your family
we'll be stuck inside the office
Chris Capel or Kapil whatever man oh
really I want to watch the first weight
[Music]
good I love how they said jigsaw they
didn't go with you know the Tobin Bell
dude it was like a family guy like
cutaway but expanded until like a
three-and-a-half minute sketch that was
brilliant I worked in an office for a
couple years and not like like a
corporate office like this but it was an
office with like other employees and
stuff since I like watch like the office
growing up I would like [ __ ] around in
the office it just reminded me of that
just like that guy who just [ __ ] with
everyone in the office
that's brilliant man that was absolutely
hilarious
it was great we watched like three great
videos today yeah it's much like a lot
of great video it's a good thing we're
taking these recommendations seriously
more seriously never again regulations
more recommendations but yeah that's
paying closer attention listen guys if
you're near the channel subscribe to the
real rejects
let's subscribe to these guys who are
these guys again Chris kick kappa this
guy Chris cope Alec Apple cable Chris
Chappell there's a missing nation isn't
there
I need a stargazer I mean this stargazer
Channel trees on Instagram one day we'll
have a gaming channel when YouTube's
algorithm forces every youtuber to leave
Tony will go